foreign
[Silence]
to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
and he began to mention the Shema in
is a word that is used in the
terminology of the scholars of Islam
specifically the scholars of Hadith
to discuss the traits of a person
so if we have many books that have been
written they are named is
many scholars will mention
either dedicate an entire book or
treaties to the subject of shemael
or will dedicate chapters and parts of
their books to a and again the
word is used in the terminology of the
scholars
namely the scholars of Hadith to
articulate a group of narrations that
mention the traits of the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam whether that
be his
physical characteristics
or that be his
you know his character his etiquette how
he behaved or anything having to do with
him
such as the names of his different
servants the names of his wives the
names of his uncles anything having to
do with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he began this
and much of what he mentioned
is
Roots back to a book authored by
who was in The Generation just before
his
may Allah have mercy on all of them
and this book is well known amongst the
scholarship of Islam especially the
scholarship of the shafiri madhep known
as
this book
begins it by discussing the Shema of the
prophets
And discussing some of his traits and
some of his etiquettes
he mentions
that this chapter is dedicated to the
character of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
Ness
foreign
[Silence]
this chapter regarding the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's character
he says that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam was of the most generous
of people
this generosity
is used to refer to a generosity which
is top tier the best there is of
generosity
and he was most generous and he was also
most
he was also most vehement in his
worship of Allah
during the nights of Ramadan
so if you could imagine
his
generosity and you could imagine his
just how incredibly
strong and consistent he was in his
discipline disciplining himself in the
worship of Allah throughout the year
yet in spite of that high quality of
discipline and generosity
he was most generous and most
disciplined during the month of Ramadan
it's been our best
tells us that the reason for this
is that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would meet
with jibril every night during the
nights of Ramadan
and he would recite what had been
revealed to him
thus far during each of those nights so
they would go through the entirety of
the Quran
and these sessions would have a great
effect on the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
Allah
[Silence]
foreign
was the best of people both in his
character and also in his
in his appearance
this is not just speaking about how he
would wear his clothing and so forth
what this is speaking about is the way
that Allah had created him he was very
very
average in a lot of
the traits that he had he was not very
tall for instance he was not very short
he was tall you would describe him as
being somewhat tall but more or less
average in height
yet somehow when he would be amongst a
group of other people he would appear
taller than the rest
and he was not very extremely short he
wasn't extremely big he wasn't emaciated
and skinny he was very average in a lot
of these things
he says
[Silence]
foreign
his hand was very gentle
he's not someone that is considered to
be rough rather he was someone who is
the majority of his trait is that of
gentleness
and he was
always smelling very good this is
something that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam took pride in and
encouraged the companions
foreign
[Silence]
your sin are slumped
the
Vietnam
foreign
[Silence]
a support
laser meme
[Silence]
foreign
escort
he's described here as being of the most
mature
and mindful of people and what's meant
here by maturity and wisdom these types
of traits
in that culture
this was a culture where
speaking less and listening more was
considered valuable this is a value that
a person of great maturity would learn
and that is that even some of the
Tiberian some of the companions
learn how to be silent and it doesn't
mean that a person is
constantly you know not speaking when
they need to speak to the point where
it's awkward rather as the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam himself said
whoever believes in Allah in the last
day than he is to speak with that which
is good or to remain silent this
remaining silent
in that culture and also in the religion
of Islam this is something which is very
valuable this is a valuable trait that a
person knows how to be quiet they know
how to listen they are few they are
few in words and much in action
foreign
[Silence]
we might not
he was also described as being
the best of people
in to live with
meaning that those who were most
comfortable around him were those who
were closest to him those who lived with
him
sometimes it is quite the opposite
usually this is the case that a person
is very pleasant to be around in person
and in public but to live with that
person is very difficult because a
person's true self
emerges when they are seen
in the place where they put their feet
up right and so most people are the
opposite most people in their home or
when they are taken out of their comfort
zone they are putting into a
an environment that they can't
necessarily control
you find that
in public they are very pleasant but
in private and to live with them or to
be acquainted with them and be
constantly around them
you would find that a person most people
would be
pretty much
outright unpleasant to live with
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was known as the best of people to live
with
foreign
[Silence]
another one of his most
compelling traits
is that he was the most courageous of
all of his companions all of the people
and courage is often misunderstood
courage is often misconstrued as being
something that only
emerges during a time of mortal danger
in war or violence and that's not
necessarily the case courage is much
more broad than that as the scholars
have mentioned courage
involves other traits of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
etiquette and of his character that are
hard to find such as
the ability to accept
from those who were
less knowledgeable than he was or to
accept from those who were his
subordinates
companions
often times he would surround himself
with the best of his companions
so if we said who are the best
companions
those were the people that he spent most
of his time with most narrations that
depict the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam going anywhere
with any of his companions
they depict him in the company of Abu
Bakr and Umar
and Abu Bakr and Omar and the rest of
his companions though they were learning
from him
he would often accept their input he
would often you know as Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala said
and seek their counsel in Affairs that
have to do with everyone this is also
part of Courage part of Courage is a
willingness to be
vulnerable to be you know to be taught
or take direction from those who are
subordinate to a person so for instance
if one of us
were to behave a certain way or do
something
and our children
were to correct us
this is a part of Courage that a person
takes the truth regardless of how he
feels at the moment or how he
this is all part of Courage likewise a
person not putting on a facade
so the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
his character usually
most people
we wear masks and we have a kind of
facade that we keep up
that we are blown away from a person's
appearance or their reputation or what
have you but if we were to get close
with this person a lot of this would
start to melt away we would see that
most of it is fluff most of it is Gossip
most of it is is almost mythical right
contrary is the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam his character was the
opposite
the more time a person spent with him
the more layers and the more depth a
person would find in his presence and
this all comes from
is rooted
in a person's courage and sincerity
courage to be sincere to be truthful to
not bloat
your self rather that a person present
himself as he is and to strive to be
better behind closed doors than one is
in public
foreign
[Silence]
and
this will reflect itself in a person's
actions in a person's behavior and a
person's etiquette that a person be
knowledgeable of Allah the more a person
as some of the saidif had mentioned men
[Silence]
as some of the
Siberian used to say that those who know
themselves best or those who get to know
themselves truly
will know
as a result of that who Allah truly is
and that is when a person looks to his
mistakes and his ignorance and person
looks to all of these things about
himself
he sees that the greater Allah
becomes a part of his life in his
conscious life
foreign
[Silence]
the most fearful of all people of Allah
and that he would refrain from becoming
angry for himself
what does this mean becoming angry for
himself
nor seeking retribution for himself
retaliating for himself
of course if a person is insulted
right person is insulted they're going
to be offended
being offended is part of being upset
that's part of being human
but a lot of times when the companions
speak about anger and refraining from
anger they're speaking about refraining
from
unleashing anger not controlling it
of a person
is insulted or feels demeaned or spoken
down to or whatever that insults people
and they get upset
this doesn't mean that they are
that they are not someone who is
haleem or not someone who is a patient
or someone no what the haleem is
the one who does not retaliate
due to
other people's errors they do not seek
retribution they do not seek to harm
those who harm them
this
is the essence
he is described as
when one of his servants
warships other than Allah or commits an
atrocity Allah
becomes angry
he says of course
but Allah
is described as haleem someone one who
is the one who is most forbearing
because he refrains from retaliation he
refrains from
harming a person immediately rather he
allows a person gives them time to
reflect to repent or pardons a person
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam we will see that throughout his
Sunnah throughout his lifetime there are
instances where people insult him where
people offend him and he takes this to
Heart of course he's a human being and
no one
of the greatest features of a human
being is a person's dignity is it a
person has self-worth
however he would
refrain from retaliating he would
refrain from harming others simply
because they harmed him
he was described as someone who did not
become angry for himself what's meant
here is he did not unleash his anger
upon those who personally offended him
nor does he personally seek retribution
and retaliation
however
he would become angry and he would
Express that anger
when a boundary of Allah was crossed if
a boundary of Allah was crossed
something Haram was committed something
against the Muslims Etc these are all
the boundaries of Allah at this he would
become angry and nothing would
nothing would relieve that anger until
he did everything in his power to right
that wrong
he was also described as
IA
who
foreign
[Silence]
likewise if he would become angry
and it was clear in his face that he was
upset
or angry about something you would see
this in his face he would have the
features of someone who is upset and he
would most likely turn away
this was the epitome of his personal
anger
is that you would see clearly that he is
visibly upset and he would turn away
however as we mentioned this is to be
coupled with the previous descriptions
that he would
take him
and his character
is the Quran
what does this mean his character
this is a famous statement of Aisha in
came and asked
about the
etiquettes and the most prominent of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam and
she summed up his etiquette and his
character and said
his character was the Quran
is he
men
was sober was
[Silence]
foreign
wasallam
[Silence]
this is a famous statement to well-known
narration
where she was asked by a group of the
tabian the tabian are the folks the
generation that
learned from The Companions
and so she was asked
describe to us the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam's character
and she described his character by
saying his character was the Quran what
is meant by this his character was the
Quran meaning anything that you read in
the Quran
and
a person is to have this feature and
this is appropriate that a human being
have this feature or this etiquette or
this characteristic and it's something
that pleases Allah you will find it in
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
whether that be Praise of Allah or
dispraise of those worshiped aside from
Allah whether that be
learning and fearing Allah
and commanding good and forbidding evil
and all of these things that we
understand from the Quran when Allah
describes himself to us
these descriptions are to have an effect
on our
actions on the way that we see the
world when a person reads about Allah's
vigilance they become Vigilant of
Allah's vigilance likewise if a person
reads of Allah's Mercy a person becomes
hopeful in what Allah has for the person
if Allah is described or something of
the description of Allah subhanahu
without his anger or Justice is
mentioned a person becomes fearful that
he be taken to account for that which he
is guilty
Etc these are the descriptions that a
human being a servant of Allah is to
derive and have from the Quran so when I
is
this is what is meant by this
foreign
[Silence]
wasallam foreign
he describes him as the most humble of
people
most humble of all the people is the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam this humbleness and this
humility
is not
to be com confused with humiliation it
was not someone who allowed himself to
be
to be degraded or someone who would
Place himself in a position of
degradation rather he was humble this is
the opposite of arrogance arrogance is
the most
disliked characteristic a person may
have to Allah
Allah
I mean the essence
of
the human being of the servant is what
humility
and the thing that does away with that
Essence and the thing that erodes that
servitude to Allah
is arrogance now arrogance is not to be
it's not something that is just you know
people say the word arrogant they're you
know if someone makes a mad they say
this person's arrogant what is arrogance
arrogance is defined by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam when he says
that a person reject the truth
and that a person belittle others look
down on others even if they treat them
the same
you know you can treat someone properly
but still
articulate that you look down upon them
that is a terrible thing that is worse
than mistreating a person
foreign
next week in his characteristics and
then move into his miracles that are
collected throughout his lifetime Allah